have you seen the grocery store robot in
the Stop and Shop yes yeah the Marty it
looks like a giant penis it's like six
feet tall it roams the aisles I will
never see Marky the same way again thank
you you're welcome
but like they these poor people were so
hard on getting a functional robot
together and then people hate Marty
because they didn't
at all consider how people would react
to Marty in their space does everybody I
mean you talk about this do do people
mostly hate Marty because I I like I
like Mario
yeah and actually like there's a there's
a parallel between the two I believe
there is so we were actually going to do
a study on this right before the
pandemic hit and then we canceled it
because we didn't want to go to the
grocery store and neither did anyone
else
um but our Theory so this was with a
student at MIT Daniella de Paola she
noticed that everyone on Facebook in her
circles was complaining about Marty
they're like what is this creepy robot
it's watching me it's always in the way
and she did this like quick and dirty
sentiment analysis on Twitter where she
was looking at positive and negative
mentions of the robot and she found that
the biggest Spike of negative mentions
happened
um when Stop and Shop threw a birthday
party for the Marty robots like with
free cake and balloons like who
complains about free cake well people
who hate Marty apparently so
and so we were like that's interesting
and then we did this like online poll we
used Mechanical Turk and we tried to
get at what people don't like about
Marty and a lot of it wasn't oh Marty's
taking jobs it was Marty is the
surveillance robot which is not it looks
for spills on the floor it doesn't
actually like look at any people
um it's it's watching as creepy as
getting in the way those were the things
that people complained about and so our
hypothesis became
is Marty a real life clippy because I
know Lex you love clippy but many people
hated clippy well there's a complex
thing there it could be like marriage a
lot of people seem to like to complain
about marriage but they secretly love it
so it could be the relationship you
might have with uh with Marty is like
oh there he goes again doing his stupid
surveillance thing but you grow to love
the um
I mean bitching about the thing that
kind of releases a kind of tension and
there's I mean some people a lot of
people show Love by sort of uh
busting each other's jobs you know like
making fun of each other and then if I
think I think people would really love
it if Marty talked back
and and like uh these are so many
possible options for humor there one you
can lean in you can be like yes I'm an
agent of the CIA monitoring your every
move like mocking people that are
concerned you know saying like yes I I'm
watching you because you're so important
with your shopping patterns I'm
collecting all this data
um or or just you know any kind of
making fun of people I don't know but I
think you hit on what exactly it is
because when it comes to robots or
artificial agents
I think people hate them more than they
would some other machine or device or
object
and it might and it might be that thing
it might be combined with love or like
whatever it is it's a more extreme
response because they view these things
as social agents and not objects and
that was
um so Clifford nass was a big human
computer interaction person and he his
theory about Clippy was that because
people viewed clippy as a social agent
when clippy was annoying and would like
bother them and interrupt them and like
not remember what they told him that's
when people got upset because it wasn't
fulfilling their social expectations and
so they complained about Clippy more
than they would have if it had been a
diff like not an not a you know virtual
character so is complaining to you a
sign that we're on the wrong path with a
particular robot or is it possible like
again like marriage like
family that there still is a path
towards that direction where we can find
deep meaningful relationship
I think we absolutely can find
meaningful relationships with more
robots and well maybe with Marty I mean
I just would I would have designed Marty
a little differently like oh isn't there
a charm to the clumsiness the slowness
there is if you're not trying to get
through the shopping cart and screaming
child you know there's I think
I think you could make it Charming I
think there are lots of design tricks
that they could have used
and one of the things they did I think
without thinking about it at all is they
slapped too big googly eyes on Marty oh
yeah and I I wonder if that contributed
maybe to people feeling watched
um
because because it's looking at them
and
so like is there a way to design the
robot to do the function that it's doing
in a way that does that people are
actually attracted to rather than
annoyed by and there are many ways to do
that but companies aren't thinking about
it now they're realizing that they
should have thought about it yeah I
wonder if there's a way to
if it would help to make Marty seem like
an entity of its own versus uh
the arm of a large corporation
so there's some sense where
this is just the camera that's
monitoring people versus this is an
entity that's a standalone entity it has
its own task
and it has its own personality like the
more personality you give it the more it
feels like
it's not sharing data with anybody else
like
when we see other human beings our basic
assumption is whatever I say to this
human being it's not like being
immediately sent to the CIA yeah what I
say to you no one's gonna hear that
right yeah that's true that's true well
you forget it I mean you do forget it I
mean I don't know if that even with
microphones here you forget that that's
happening but there for some reason I
think probably with Marty
um I think when it's done really crudely
and crappily you start to realize oh
this is like PR people trying to make a
friendly version of a surveillance
machine